and finally new rule you can't have so
much money that my computer spellcheck
doesn't know what to call you
Jeff Bezos is poised to be the world's
first trillionaire the headline says
even my phone was like that can't be
right but it probably is because we now
live in an age not of innovation but of
domination startups are in a 13-year
slump and financing is down 22% from 8
years ago because in the online
marketplace Amazon has become the only
game in town and that was before an
event happened that made everyone stay
home and order everything online yeah I
mean predictably once the virus hit and
America locked itself upstairs like a
babysitter hiding from a slasher sure of
course the rest of the economy cratered
but Amazon stock price is up 25% that's
what I call asymptomatic places like
j.crew and stage stores Neiman Marcus
JCPenney Sears Pier one they're all
throwing in the towel as it seems one of
the unintended consequences of our
Korona response is everyone going out of
business at the same time except Amazon
while we're all inside getting softer
and hairier it's out there getting
bigger and stronger and if we don't do
something we're gonna come out of our
holes and discover that there's only one
store and it knows where you live you
know there was a famous folk song from
the 1950s called 16 tons and like all
folk songs it was horrible but it did
raise awareness about the problem of
having just one store cuz it was about
the old mining towns where the workers
only had the one company store the
chorus went 16 tons and what do you get
another day older and deeper in debt
Saint Peter don't call me because I
can't go I own my soul to the company
store
like I said folk songs are horrible
but at least back then we understood
that getting everything from one store
was a bad thing but that was BP before
prime you might be surprised to learn
that elizabeth warren had a plan to
break up amazon and i say let's go for
it like senator warren I'm a capitalist
to my core but when a company gets so
big it smothers all competitors in the
crib
that's anti-capitalist like when Amazon
destroyed the startup diapers.com by
cutting Amazon's own diaper costs below
cost by one estimate Bezos lost a
hundred million dollars in his quest to
corner the online diaper market but he
owns it now which raises the question
what is wrong with this man Jesus okay
you had one brilliant idea that when
people get drunk at home they'll go
online and buy [ __ ] they don't need
great congratulations you won you're the
best at making money but one of the
rules of the game of capitalism is you
can win big but not so big there's no
game we've been through this before a
century ago when john d rockefeller was
personally worth two percent of
america's GDP and his Standard Oil
Company became such an overwhelming
monopoly that Congress wrote the Sherman
Antitrust Act to break it up but
Rockefeller had only one product oil
Amazon sells 119 million different items
and when one supplier brings you
everything you're not a customer you're
independent
and look I use Amazon of course everyone
does I'm not saying Amazon is pure
unadulterated evil that's Wells Fargo
but Amazon does prey upon the Achilles
heel of the American character we will
sell our soul for convenience liberals
are supposed to be environmentalists
they must notice how wrong it is for us
to do so much of our shopping in such a
way
vil piggish manor does anyone really
need a grill cover to get to you
overnight and in a separate box from
something you ordered the day before
from the same warehouse when I was a kid
getting a package was a rare event now
kids think the UPS man is their dad what
what is socks need a protective air
cushion I'm gonna shove my foot in it
and stomp on it all day they ship a
disposable razor in a box the size of a
coffin and enough plastic to choke a
whale which it eventually does and I
haven't even mentioned that Amazon often
pays no taxes and bathroom breaks for
their workers are so infrequent they
have to pee into bottles which are then
resold as kombucha maybe this is just
the hunter/gatherer in me speaking but
someday I hope to leave the cave again
and I'm gonna want to shop somewhere in
person so this weekend be a hero and go
out to an actual store and patronize
some other business besides Amazon and
let's see if we can't get America back
on its feet again because we're looking
pretty raggedy and you know the old
saying if the shoe fits you probably
didn't get it online
you